[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them the new speaker is too woke for
manga is this where we're
at the election denier the guy who
wanted to overturn the 2020 election in
favor of Donald Trump the guy who who
who hates women I mean this guy he
[__] hates women like he hates them
Mike Mike Ro Johnson the new wiener of
the
house he did an interview with Shan
Hannity last night we're going to watch
a few of those clips to break down like
where he's moving the needle because he
knows he knows a couple different things
he's gota he's got to do a stop Gap to
keep the government open if he wants any
chance to remain the speaker of the
house which it's wild stuff that this
guy is even the speaker of the house I
actually I had my doubts the other day
because this guy came out of nowhere
he's not in leadership um my guess is
though is that he's made deals one
indication that he's made deals is the
vacate rule they want to change the
vacate rule so it seems like that they
made that deal that MAA would would let
this guy who's
MAA who loves Trump who is an election
ner who's a woman hater remember the uh
Little Rascals they had the He-Man Woman
Haters Club this guy's Spanky he's like
the head of the He-Man Woman Haters Club
you know what I
mean well he he definitely definitely is
a Christof fascist right
white Christian nationalist as I like to
refer to them a little easier to
understand in the dialect of the
Americana the white Christian
nationalist he's definitely a Nazi right
but it's weird because the morning MAA
and the fascist
right [__] hates this guy because of
an interview that he did on PBS and I'm
gonna I'm gonna show you how the AI
stuff I've been talking about the reason
why I've been saying it I know it seems
like Tony's talking a lot about AI but
I'm I'm telling you what it why it is so
important in the narrative and why we
have to understand it so that we know
how to use it to advance democracy or
use it to work against people to trying
to hurt
democracy right I mean I mean let me let
me let me give it to you in a better way
if us if us as a country
because we don't like what China does
with their Navy we're like well we're
just going to get rid of the Navy
because obviously Navy is bad having a
Navy is bad because China's doing a lot
of bad stuff with their
Navy we wouldn't get rid of our Navy
it's not what we would do that's not
what so we're building ships in other
words we're building aircraft carriers
we're building the building blocks of
our AI Navy here on the left to combat
the AI Navy on the right if that makes
sense but they're already blaming a clip
of Mike
Johnson making this claim and apparently
it is true that he adopted a
14-year-old black son and he refers to
them in this clip and he sympathizes
with his 14-year-old black son as the
difference between his 14-year-old white
son and he admits that yes there there
is White Privilege in this clip and I'm
mean the right is going wild over this
they're running wild with it Matt Walsh
even quote tweeting Patriot takes which
is some weird ass
[__] some weird ass [__] that Patriot
takes is putting out a clip and it's
it's infuriating the right usually
Patriot takes is going and grabbing
clips of the right-wing saying some
crazy [__] to outrage the left do you
see the difference do you see where
we're going do you see how we keep
driving this narrative we keep driving
it and driving it mocking them and
mocking them they fall for the
mockery and they properly mock
themselves and they set the ball up on
the T4
us and they they
become the the the pudding that makes
the cake right so it is so important
that we understand in the sense of
mocking and making sure that we're
defending democracy of why it is so
important to have our AI tools so that
we can use them to save democracy
against their weapon of their AI tools
to try to destroy it because the
rightwing is already
divided they're already dividing up into
the camp of oh this is AI right we play
the song here and I'm gonna play it
later is this AI or is this real or is
it AI I already forgot the song we got a
few new more songs uh for you today here
on the Tony Michaels podcast that's what
we do is we just you know we just create
stuff now for you as we go and as we as
you guys help us make this show what it
truly is is a crown sourced way to yell
and scream with a cathartic strategic
outrage to bash the fascist right in
this country make them crawl back
underneath their
Rock so I appreciate having every single
one of you here on Friday Friday Friday
let's see what else what else is in the
crazy news um we're going to go over
this interview with the the new um the
new wiener of the house um but also
there's a Supreme Court case which I'm
very interested in getting into the
bottom of to it's it's called the Trump
to too small case apparently some
California lawyer um he trademarked the
phrase with the political message
mocking Donald Trump trump too small uh
and it's going to the Supreme Court so
we're going to um I'm I'm gonna try to
figure out what the hell this is uh and
figure out this story today on the air
so if you guys got anything that you
want to contribute here or scream out
into the chat we'll try to make sure
that we we find out about this story
because I can't wait to get to the
bottom of this story and I'm hoping that
we can
um
maybe inflame the
situation Chris Christine says bash the
fash yeah that's what we do here on the
Tony Michaels podcast properly as we
bash the fash so we're going to do that
today um as we mock the mockery because
isn't that funny so someone's making a
t-shirt design Trump too small goes to
Supreme Court under copyright laws right
and it's it's mockery so we're going to
mock them trying to stop the mockery
today so it's like different levels
different tear of mocking these idiots
and mocking their sensibility right
because that's truly that's truly what
it is is they're
snowflakes they're such
snowflakes oh my God it's why the Cheeto
dust Qin onor goes in front of a a
courtroom in New York and pisses and
moans and [__] and whines about how
[__] bad he's got it and all these
people like yeah he's our he's our wher
and cheap and we love him when he whines
like God
damn when are you people sick and tired
of him [__] complaining so much like
have you ever seen anyone who complains
more and better than Donald Trump
[__] Jesus
Christ have you ever had to like go to
work you know because work you don't
really get to choose right you don't get
to choose to be around these people
necessarily you're almost forced to
sometimes when you work with people or
if you're like at you know you work
somewhere and they customers or some
[__] you know what I mean and there is
whining like I'm sure a lot of you have
been in the service industry at some
point in your life where you're either
in retail or you worked at a restaurant
you know something like that or some
sort of customer service at all and
there's just a Karen just bitching and
moaning and whining about [__] that they
can't control and [__] you can't control
like come on will you [__] just stop
please good
Lord just pay the bill we you ate all
the food you're saying it was nasty but
you ate the whole plate of food why are
you bitching now you're bitching now
that you ate the whole plate of food now
you don't want to pay for it get the
[__] out of here that's basically what
he's doing he ate the whole plate of
food Donald Trump took advantage of the
entire system this entire time lying
committing fraud getting away with it
and now and it made him it made him
appear Rich Beyond on toothless rednecks
wildest dreams right and now he's
pissing and moaning that he got away
with it this whole time and he should
still be getting away with it you know I
came in here last week and I ordered a
steak and it was good but I said it was
nasty and I ate the whole thing I even
eat the ters and the green beans and
drank 14 Diet Cokes and let me tell you
something last week when I pissed and
moaned they gave it to me for free and I
want it for free this week you gave it
to me last week get the [__] out of here
with this whining and pissing and
moaning good
Lord so we're gonna we're gonna properly
mock Donald Trump uh
today for Trump too small that we're
gonna mock the mockery um also we have
it's weird because I haven't track down
this story yet either apparently uh Joe
Biden is not going to appear in the New
Hampshire Democratic Prime primary
ballot uh though the right in remains an
option so and I haven't Tracked Down the
story but essentially what this story is
saying is that the New Hampshire
Democratic primary won't have Joe Biden
on the ballot right okay stay with me
here this is
important but they're gon people are GNA
be able to write him in
okay now in New Hampshire I believe if I
remember correctly in the Democratic
primary um when the the the
popular vote of the primary election
Awards them certain delegates and then
there's super delegates in New Hampshire
as well do you see that so there's two
type of delegates that the New Hampshire
primary Awards awards candidates right
super
delegates and then just regular old
delegates ballot delegates that the
people of New Hampshire choose by their
vote and it's a lot of times those
delegates are awarded at a convention
right depends on the state the state but
here's the thing so we're going to have
a situation in New Hampshire where Joe
Biden is going to run away with the
nomination in New Hampshire in this
primary literally he's gonna take the
primary he's gonna have a writing
campaign he's gonna have super delegates
and he's gonna have all the other
delegates right only proving more to the
point that there's no one going to
challenge Joe Biden oh but there is
there's some sort of [__] who's this
Congressman Dean Phillips
and what right winger is backing Dean
Phillips apparently there's a there is a
challenger he announced on Friday that
he's gonna challenge Joe Biden well this
is gonna go over like a wet fart and a
white thong isn't
it and again the New Hampshire primary
is only going to prove the point that
I've been yelling and screaming for the
past six eight months when people are
like oh we need choices you did have a
choice in 2020 you [__]
boneheads and yes I'm calling people on
the left [__] boneheads you had a you
had a choice listen you had a choice in
20120 to elect the Democratic nominee
for president of United States there was
a whole cache of Democrats there was
Pete Buddha judge there was there was
Bernie Sanders there was there was
Andrew Yang you remember that [__]
idiot uh let Tulsi gabard when she used
to be a Democrat she never was a
Democrat she was always a Russian assent
she's a plant by the way if you didn't
catch on to that and we had Elizabeth
Senator Elizabeth Warren on the stage uh
you had Tom Styer some billionaire right
some weird ass Android billionaire he
was on and he still gives a lot to
democratic causes but he was on the
stage you had the choice of picking
between those people in
2020 because there wasn't an
incumbent you realize that right there
wasn't an incumbent but now that there
is because a president only gets two
terms I don't know if you know that
either you only get two shots at it okay
that's why it's weird that that um
Donald Trump is taking another shot at
it because you don't normally get more
than two shots because you got a chance
for two terms but he's taken another
stab at it he's gonna lose but you know
whatever the hell they want to do the
more losing on their side the better off
it is for us here on the pro democracy
Coalition side
but it's not yeah KLA Harris was in
there right K I think wasn't even Maran
Williamson the one that tyt acts like
she was gonna be the the [__] nominee
like no Marian Williamson that crazy
lunatic can definitely beat Joe Bon come
on I just can't because he's the
incumbent president the only way that an
incumbent
president can is not the party nominee
out automatically is if they lose the
trust of the superdelegates and the
superdelegates is the party that's what
it is they're card caring party members
most of them are elected officials folks
they are people the Democratic party has
voted to be their leaders in their
party that's how it [__]
works I don't understand why people
don't get that there is not going even
Gavin Newsome as popular as he may be
amongst amongst the Democratic primary
voters even he couldn't beat Joe Biden
Gavin Nome that's why he's not running
understands that because Gavin Nome he
understands how the the presidential
Democratic primary process
works that's how it works and I know
that some people are like I don't want
Joe Biden he's this or he's that and E
he's got wrinkly ball s or some [__] you
know like whatever they whatever they're
saying he's got a set of wrinkly
balls
whoever this is with the last name s
Chee whoever this is with the last name
s
Chee whoever this is with the l name s
cheese what are you talking about oh
what that's a personal attack oh oh I
see the wi
that these these immature people on stay
I've got to whoever this is with the
last
[Music]
name whoever this is with the last name
sa
CH whoever this is with the last sh six
ch
there we go now I'm good to go here we
we go hello Fellers out there the
[__] fam I don't know what the hell
happened if you want to know the Qui
honest truth I don't
know I'm back I'm back you son [__]
it must be it must be the AI right-wing
uh Bots out there I told you this shit's
gonna get
real I'm a little loud yeah it'll even
out in a second uh let me see if I can
get
the there we go is that better how's my
how's my mic now rat
is it doing good did it did it even out
was I hot there for a second oh boy well
we didn't lose too much of the audience
here we didn't lose too much maybe
they'll come back and they'll they'll
view they'll
view it happens I don't know what
happened it went crazy it went
crazy yeah um glitchy Mitchy it's
glitchy Tony today it's glitchy Tony
today all right I'm good and Jim Jim
says I'm good and we're back and we're
ready to go all right what the hell was
I talking about before all hell broke
loose
here oh boy oh yes we were talking about
the Democratic primary and Joe
Biden so again even Gavin Nome even
Gavin Nome understands that he cannot
beat Joe Biden because of the
superdelegates and how the party
works oh yes that's what it was you're
right
I can I get a beer said Tony froze on
wrinkly
balls they're watching oh my God they're
like oh God damn he's talking about Joe
Biden's wrinkly
balls wrinkly balls I I think what we
need to do next time too is we need to
get uh Rat we need to get a graphic that
we can put up on the screen that way
anytime you know this happens we can
like um we can get we can get like a
technical difficulties you know what I
mean like maybe um maybe some beep boop
noises from the laboratory because that
that's probably what's happening is you
know the laboratory and the the show
aren't aren't
communicating oh boy wrinkly balls is
where the broadcast fell off well if
you're listening to the audio version
because we're going to cut that out like
we're going to cut the the the the show
cutting
off um so if you're listening what
happened was is in Midstream my computer
crashed and it turned back on and I
don't know if it's going to do it again
like I I don't know it might need an
update or it might be compromised by the
by the
AI maybe iony is is alive it's live it's
live R go back in the laboratory evening
Fixit Tony make sure he doesn't make us
crash again all right all right ball
gate someone says um here yeah w
Harris's ball gate on the Tony Michaels
podcast this morning all right let's get
back to the uh the stories at hand here
because I I really want to um Talk a few
more I guess apparently um you know
we're talking about the two uh Trump too
small the the T-shirt but um speaking of
too small speaking of too small um
there's going to be a stop Gap so
they're not going to pass a CR so
they're not again
I I think I um I think I told you this a
couple weeks ago when we were talking
about the 45 day stop Gap uh that they
would pass another stop Gap to get past
the holidays right because they don't
want the government to shut down during
the holidays they'll shut down you know
if they shut down the government you
know 45 days ago that was well before
the holidays that was well before people
would think it was the holidays but they
can't do it now like the 17th of
November oh [__] they're going to shut
down the government right before
Thanksgiving think about that now you
and all your [__] family some that
are got brain cells to rub together that
make thoughts and others that
don't are going to get together and
start talking about how they shut down
the government they don't want that [__]
spreading far and wide and these
narratives Crossing because that's where
narratives cross in this country is when
you get families together generally
speaking you know because you got your
your [__] your farm fash Facebook
Uncle
Fred uh sitting at the table talking
about all kinds of crazy [__] he read on
the the interwebs well it says on there
that Joe Biden he doesn't have wrinkly
balls it says he doesn't have balls at
all that's what I read on those xener
webs back to the wrinkly balls right but
you're your your farm fash Facebook
Uncle
Fred uh is definitely going to say [__]
at the the table on
Thanksgiving and you know you're gonna
punch back with the with the um the
government shutdown stuff and you might
just
convince your farm fash Facebook Uncle
Fred
that what you're saying about the
shutdown and the Republicans being not
able to govern is true and that's the
problem that they don't want right they
don't want to have that that in the
American discourse at that point nor do
they want the narrative that the the
Republicans are responsible
for the Republicans are responsible
Everyone likes the Uncle Fred thing uh
yeah well Farm Fresh fash Uncle Fred
Facebook Uncle Fred and Jim Jim points
out here Fred and Uncle Earl yeah Fred
and Earl are brothers right you know
this is this is my uh well how to go on
The Bob new AR show this is my brother
is it Earl no it's not Earl what is
it this my
brother Dwayne no not Dwayne was Dwayne
what the hell what the hell was the
brother's name then my Daryl this is my
brother Daryl and this yeah that's it
this is my other brother
Daryl Crystal has it heing it's my
brother Daryl and this my other brother
Daryl so Fred's got two brothers named
darl and a brother named Earl there's
four
brothers there they're dumb [__] and
they love Facebook though and they share
this [__] out of all their ridiculous
stuff on Facebook you know what I'm
talking about you got an uncle Daryl you
got an Uncle Earl you got an uncle Fred
you know what I'm saying
right so they don't want to shut down
the government right before the holidays
too because that would really piss
people off if you somehow hindered their
ability to
travel somehow hindered their ability to
I don't know buy Christmas presents or
have a Christmas dinner because you [__]
the economy or [__] their personal
economy they really don't want that to
happen so they're gonna pass a Scot stop
Gap like I said and punt it past the
holidays because they definitely want to
shut down the government they just want
to do it strategically so they think it
benefits
them quick secret it's not going to
benefit them and the reason why is
because we are standing in their way
with the narrative that's the whole
point that's why we got to stay out in
front of their [__] fashion ISM and
that's why we have to build the AI
weapons to use against the AI weapons
that they're going to use of
misinformation because I was describing
yesterday World War III is already on
it's been on for a long time it's just a
matter of the perspective of where the
war is being fought and the war is being
fought in the arena of
misinformation so we have to and really
honestly it's a difficult battle folks
it's not easy you know the old adage
by the time the truth gets up and puts
on its shoes the LIE has made its way
around the world six times or whatever
the adage
is whatever version of it that you
like and un that's an unfortunate
truth that we have to deal with in this
war of
misinformation but we will deal with
it we
will so they're not but they don't want
that narrative to be used against them
so they're not going to shut down the
government I mean it appears that Mike
Johnson has made the
deal that he will get funding for
Ukraine tied to Israel it appears he's
made the deal that they will kick the
shutdown until sometime in January or
February and it appears that he is going
to be able to change the vacate vote the
vacate motion because we know from Kevin
McCarthy's failure as a leader of the
house as Speaker Matt gats was able to
bring one motion to the floor with one
vote to bring a
vacate which led to
the the
stupidity that Kevin McCarthy thought he
wasn't going to be vacated from the
speaker of the house it took him 14
times to get there and the deals that he
had to make were
ridiculous and the deals that Mike
Johnson Johnson is making is ridiculous
ridiculous now here's the good news
folks the farm fresh fash are
already
fighting rather Mike Johnson is fascist
enough rather he's racist enough rather
he is too
woke to
be part of the farm fresh
fash I like that Farm Fresh
fash it's got a ring to it your farm
fresh fash Facebook Uncle
Fred um do we have rant do we have um do
we have the ability to get us an image
of of the farm fresh fash Facebook Uncle
Fred do we have that ability I'm pretty
sure we can get a good image for the
folks here for that I know we I got a
couple images I got to show you when we
come back from the break and I'm excited
to do that we're also going to watch um
this clip that the rightwing is really
piss off about oh man they're super
pissed and you definitely should not
spread it around the internet wink um
but what you're going to want to do is
go to the Tony
michaels.com for me do this for me this
is a big favor for me go subscribe to
the Tony michaels.com at the top you can
always find the current episode rather
we're live or the farm fresh fash is
trying to shut us down when I'm talking
about Joe Biden's wrinkly balls um if
you want to get in on live show support
if you want to get in on the screen go
to the vinmo Super Chat tab I'll keep
I'll keep my eyes on that if you want to
get a message on screen to me uh you can
go to vinmo chat you can put it in the
vinmo chat make sure you include your
handle name in the platform that you're
on so I can give you a proper shout out
if you just want to buy me a shot you
know I love Jagermeister or if you swear
like I do you can put money in the swear
jar to help support the show but I also
want to point this out there's
memberships going on here on Theon
michaels.com and they're free all these
are free to join now you can go to
patreon.com and you can follow me for
free now there is paid membership and I
appreciate all the support over there
that you can give on patreon you get
extras by by giving your support whether
it's the $5 tier the $10 tier the $20
tier you get those extras um but it is
free to follow now and you're going to
want to because I have been posting
those articles that the AI Tony is
generating we refer to him right now as
iony until the chat comes up with a
better name I kind of like Terminator
Tony but that's getting into copyright
too you know I might end up in the
Supreme Court room like the Trump too
small
T-shirt um so I Tony too I don't know
what kind of [__] copyright Apple has
on putting I in front of any word but I
don't know we're we'll cross that we'll
cross that copyright bridge when we get
there but if you want to go read the
articles that iony is producing this
morning was has plenty of [__] in it
I'm really training I was telling the um
speaking of patreon a Discord I was
telling in the producers Corner we do a
special producers Corner every single
Friday and Monday before the show where
we just have a chat with each other I
was telling them this morning that I'm
training iony to really curse better
he's getting better at it iony is
finally learning how to curse he's
getting out of his adolescence and he's
really trying to put the profanity
poetry to use um so go over to patreon
and follow follow me over there on
patreon it's free and you can read those
articles for free you can also join the
Discord server for free you should do
that you should not U you should
definitely get in on the Discord server
we're going to play a lot of games over
there now there's going to be some cool
stuff coming so I'm gonna put the
Discord server Link in the chat uh so
everyone can get over there on the
Discord server when you go to the
Discord server click the check mark the
green check mark to verify and also if
you have an Amazon Prime account you can
link it to your Twitch account the
directions are right here as well all
right that's enough self
promotion we're going to go to a break
we'll come right back hopefully we'll
have all the farm fresh fash out of my
computer and it won't you know do what
it did earlier and freak out on us don't
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
podcast fellow Patriots
what would you do if there was a trump
supporter right in front of you crying
in pain because they have to live under
communist tyranny we know what you would
do you'd reach out and give that true
American a hand now here's your chance
for only $50 a day you can help us help
those true Americans recover from
Biden's socialist reign of terror these
are those Trump supporters and this is
that moment send your donation via venmo
to the real president Donald J Trump
it's only $50 a day
recurring well we're
back oh boy I tell you what it's um one
thing after another
[Music]
here I I don't know if the commercial
got played or not I'm not really sure
um you know what um
let's see if we can
play Let's get to let's see it was
playing it was playing I I couldn't see
I couldn't see in the um whether it was
playing or not I guess it did
play oh boy yeah yep yep yep there's
there's some crazy stuff going on with
uh what we're we're working with today
but that's how it goes that's how it
goes um you know what here's what I
here's what I want to do I want to bring
rat up here for a second if rat can if
rat can come on back to the show for a
second rat here's what I want you to do
um can you pull up on your
side uh a a picture or a you know what
pull up a video um that that we might
have of um of something going on and I'm
gonna go out and come back in you know
what I mean so when the video starts
playing I'm going to go out and come
back in if you can play any video you
want just pick out one that you want
uh and we've got images coming in so if
you can just uh I don't know when I
notice that you have the video up there
uh you can hit play on the video uh and
we'll uh I'll go out and I'll come back
in um that way that way we've got it we
we don't have any kind of more stuff in
the show um some people are saying they
thought the the commercial was cut it
off yeah it is it is it is cut off it is
cut off okay I see you got the video
there go ahead and start playing it and
then I'll I'll come back here in a
little bit um you can go ahead and put
it up on the stage he tries to do I'm
gonna cut off his dick and shove it up
his ass so far he'll be [__] out his
own balls enough is enough with this
[__] for people wondering this
is going to be a 247 stream Trump forget
sleepy Joe let me tell you something
Jack it's dark Brandon time and we're
going down into a rabbit hole so deep
even Quan will be shaking in their boot
so come on boys and girls grab your
popcorn because today we're going to
make twitch history and piss off all the
sensitive little snowflakes out there
grab your Maga hats or not cuz we ain't
holding
back listen up [__] let me tell
you something sleepy Joe no one wants to
hear your policy crap okay as for your
golden shower fantasies let me make one
thing clear it's all fake news total and
complete [__] and let me tell you a
sleepy Joe can't even hand handle his
own shadow forget about handling the
country speaking of which did you see
that Hunter Biden got caught with his
pants down literally oh boy do I feel
sorry for whatever lady is unfortunate
enough to be on the receiving end of
that mess listen up Jack and as for
Hunter Biden let me tell you that man's
got a big [__] dick unlike that tiny
mushroom dick of yours you know what's
tremendous the fact that you're such a
pathetic loser that you have to resort
to spreading lies about my family to
make yourself feel better but guess what
[__] AI Biden is here to shut
you the [__]
down okay we had the AI Biden and AI
Trump joining us um while we got our
technical difficulties situated out I I
think I may be good now I'm not really
sure um but it looks like rant's got a
picture of us for the farm fresh
Facebook fash here is the oh my god wow
this is really accurate here is the farm
fresh Facebook fash here uh this is your
Uncle Fred you'll be talking to him and
he's he's canning those green beans you
know last week we had him canning green
beans here's that's that that's wild
that's how fast it was look how great
that is folks can you believe that stuff
look at
that you talking about AI working fast
quick and in a
hurry that's crazy but there is um
there's there's Farm Fresh fash Uncle
Fred Facebook Uncle
Fred um this is what AI can
do oh my god oh someone says fesus no
it's Uncle Fred Festus is their is their
grandpappy he was the farm fresh F fesus
and really honestly you know that's the
weird part you know then we're talking
about this is that a lot of these fies
and thanks rat I appreciate all the the
help for the technical difficulties and
and thanks for the um the AI Biden video
and keeping that going um this is the
weird part about this in like American
discourse and rural areas that at one
point in this country you know you you
you kind of see these people like oh our
farm has been in our generation for for
or been in our family for three
generations my grandpappy's grandpappy
what they don't know is during like the
Great
Depression the original socialist in
this country were the
farmers the farm bill is
socialism it's socialism by Design like
they don't understand that it's weird
stuff speaking of Facebook and Farm
Fresh fash it's like years ago when
Obama was still the
president um when Obama was the
president and they were working on the
farm bill and Republic an for years
really tried to separate the farm bill
and or get welfare out of the farm bill
so the farm subsidies and and food
stamps were always in the farm Bild the
reason why is that's what makes it
work that's why it worked for for so
long that's why it worked still is that
what you do is you provide government
money the government buys the food right
if the farmer can't sell it on the open
market Market they buy the food by
subsidy that's what you're doing is
you're buying
it and then the people who can't afford
to
buy inm Market food at like a grocery
store where the farmer you know makes
their food and then distributes it to
the grocery store through different
Supply chains and then the end user goes
to the grocery store to buy it if they
can't afford to buy it the government's
like we'll give you food stamps that way
we don't have poor ass Farmers not being
able to afford to live on farms and
people who will pay them to make the
food and then we'll make sure the people
who need the food can eat it makes sense
right and it works it [__] works not
only does it work it works exceptionally
well because it's called what is that
word called economy that's what it's
called it's a great economy it creates
an economy and a market oh oh baby these
capitalists really love those type of
words
right but they don't understand that
farm subsidies is socialism so years ago
when Obama was trying to work on getting
the farm bill passed and it it didn't
seem like he was going to get it passed
I literally had friends in my Ru town
that were posting on Facebook you know
along with the the farm fresh fash
Facebook Uncle Fred they were posting on
Facebook oh they need to pass this this
farm bill so us farmers can get our sub
idies we need our
subsidies and then the same
feed as the farm fresh Facebook Uncle
Fred they were like but we don't want
people to have food
stamps that damn you lazy people having
food stamps like holy [__] how don't you
get that you're making
food and that the government making sure
that people who can't eat or can't
afford eat are eating with I don't know
money gets back in your pocket how do
you not understand
this this is easy stuff like abc1 two3
type
[__] and they were bitching about the
farm bill not being passed and they were
bitching about food stamps being
passed wild [__] because it's the old
the old thing that I say several times
I've said it several times on the show I
want my rich white welfare but I don't
want you to have your poor poor Brown
welfare because that's truly how they
feel about it that's truly how they feel
about it is there's there's there's rich
white that's that's earned that's earned
benefits but you poor brown people
you're a Scourge on our
country even though there's no proof in
that and and matter of fact there's
proof to the
opposite that people who come here
migrants and other other populations
actually work their asses off
and they get paid less they get less
money for the same work the same output
dum dum and the one reason why is
because you're getting our tax dollars
to grow the food to make sure people who
are hungry have it to eat and really
we've done a piss Bo job since Nixon if
you really want to go back into the
history of it of feeding people now some
states are coming on board and some
people have come to the realization that
we actually have the infastructure to
feed families in this country we we have
the infrastructure it's a very easy
infrastructure we use the infrastructure
every [__] day in this country to
feed families every day we use this
infrastructure it's called School
cafeterias we literally have built an
entire infrastructure in this country
that not only educates people but feeds
them every day every single school has
some sort of cafeteria inside of it
Elementary uh middle school high school
wherever it may be those public schools
have
cafeterias and uh cafeterias are
designed to uh what is it feed people so
we have the infrastructure that feeds
families every single day in this
country and during the pandemic if you
remember a lot of people couldn't afford
school lunches because I don't know
there was a
pandemic so what the government did is
said you know what we're going to do
we're going to make all lunch free lunch
we're not going to charge anybody we're
going to pay for the lunch for every
single student in this country to eat
and by doing that the government paid
for families to eat it's actually a
really simple infrastructure it it
exists
already it's not complicated to
understand this I actually don't know
why um there isn't a big National push
for this type of program like you know
like everyone's wants to get on the you
know there's always been these leftist
kind of movements the free college thing
H you know eliminate all student debt
you remember Bernie Sanders wanted to
eliminate every single penny of student
debt with a stroke of a pen Joe Biden
actually tried it and it didn't work
because Republicans stood in the way
because they don't want Americans to get
any kind of benefits from government at
all I mean unless it's their rich white
benefit don't forget that they
definitely want their rich white
benefits um but why aren't we talking
about how to feed America every single
Community has has their own Community
cafeteria built
in those families have the ability to go
to those
buildings most of them you could and and
normally unless they get the voucher
system that they want where people don't
have schools in their communities
anymore because they're private they're
using taxpayer dollars to pay private
corporations to give rich people the
best education in this country but
almost every single Community has a
school close by to their community right
that's the design of public education
that's the whole [__] design and
there's a cafeteria there with equipment
and the ability to make food for large
groups of people like in the
community I mean my proposition would be
that hey let's feed
America there's cafeterias on in every
Community let's use those cafeteras
let's make sure those families not just
the children of those that attend those
schools but
the parents of those children can go eat
at that
cafeteria why not why wouldn't we do
that you have any idea how much how much
of a dent we'd make in
hunger and it wouldn't cost him a dime
wouldn't cost him a dime we'd use
federal dollars and we tax the rich we'd
make Elon Musk pay just a little bit
more like I don't know actually pay
taxes on his private yacht and his
private jet and just pay for people to
eat oh man that's a [__] it's a
[__] wild idea is't it oh man we
can't do that Tony we need hunger people
in this country we need hungry people in
this country as the farm fresh Uncle
Fred cans his green beans to sell
growing his farm fresh food bitching
about how he chooses who gets to eat
it I know that was a roundabout thing
but there you go speaking of wild wild
czy czy [__] and rich white welfare and
poor Brown welfare and comparing things
and using the race card holy [__] did
you hear about Mike
Johnson Mike
Johnson is apparently way too
woke for the farm fresh fash let me show
you here uh the patrio takes had a clip
a couple days ago and it's only really
kind of got attention now
that the right wing is like you mother
woker oh my God you're so woke here is
um here's Matt Walsh you guys remember
Matt Walsh from me bashing on this fash
from the show he's the one that like
he's really weird about like U
children's genitalia is really he says
really weird [__] often he says really
weird [__] about uh children's genitalia
like he gets he gets all confused used
and Matt Walsh is like oh yeah that
lgbtq wieners and vaginas and he's
immediately goes immediately goes to
genitalia now this guy loves Hitler he
loves Nazis and he is one but he says
here a full-fledged endorsement of the
left's radical
narrative right notice the words here
the left's radical
narrative from the gop's new house
speaker so I'm going to show you this uh
this
clip of mikro Johnson here the wiener of
the house the new wiener of the house uh
and Patriot takes posted this video on
October 25th so two days ago Patriot
take says new GOP house Speaker Mike
Johnson believes white people have quote
an easier path in life than black people
because of the color of their skin which
is true holy [__] Mike Johnson every
once in a while tells the
truth now it's kind of demeaning the way
that he tells it I'm not going to lie
here um when you listen to it you're
going to be kind of like oh that's
gross and it's kind of weird that we're
gonna weaponize this in the narrative
and get the get get the farm fresh fash
to punch each other in the face right
like that's what they're going to do
they're gonna we're g to drive wedges
down in between their narrative
here um but Johnson claims in this clip
on PBS that Johnson said the country
needs quote systematic change and
transformative solutions to address this
which I can only imagine what Mike
Johnson's idea of systematic change and
transformative Solutions are that scares
the [__] out of me when you're talking
about the guy who was saying the [__] he
was saying about partial birth abortion
the other day in front of a medical
doctor and the medical doctor's like
whatat you're describing is not a thing
you're living in fantasy land and that
fantasy land is
weird Mike Johnson now the question
becomes who is Mike Johnson
right we don't know who he is he's a
representative from Louisiana he hasn't
been a
congressman it's the election Speaker of
the House there you
go there's some new
music he's the election denying speaker
of the house he denies the election he
wanted to overturn it I showed you a
video last uh earlier on the week where
he want he was really disappointed that
they couldn't overturn the 20120
election in
December he's from Louisiana right he
hates women loves religion oh man loves
him some white Christian
nationalist loves
that but here's the thing Mike Johnson
apparently adopted a 14-year-old
boy I know when I say that out loud and
you're talking about a republican it
gets kind of hairy right like
immediately like what he did
what
now the thing is is that Mike Johnson
adopted a 14-year-old
boy and he was he was black
right and apparently this is this is
true now the problem is is that this
really throws wrenches when Mike Johnson
when Mike Johnson micro Johnson went on
a PBS interview when he never thought
that he was gonna be the Speaker of the
House Mike Johnson never ran for
congress thinking he was gonna be the
speaker of the house no [__] way no
[__] way this guy last week never
dreamed he was gonna be the speaker of
the house no [__]
way oh yes you're right you're right rat
pointing something out here it's the
less racial narrative so I I read that
wrong I apologize I apologize radical
racial though it's racial narrative it's
the black lives matter thing I excuse me
excuse me I even highlighted it and I
got it wrong you're right you're right
see this is the thing when I'm wrong I
will admit that I'm wrong if I said
something out of turn I will admit it I
would admit it and usually it's because
I can't read worth the [__] oh what is
that we rat rat do we have do we have
something do we have do you have
something you want to show us here rat
is that is that what you got you got
something going on here no are you just
are you just bragging are you just
bragging about correcting me is that
what you're doing is that what you're
doing is you're bragging about
correcting me because it feels like
you're bragging here if you have
something just let us know um enough of
the running
laps all right as you guys know small
rat is in the laboratory all the time
let's see if he's let's see if he's in
in a laboratory right now I'll um let's
see we do we have him in the laboratory
right now oh yes we do we do we have we
have him here here here he is oh boy
that laboratory is getting much bigger
rat it's getting much bigger and also
what are all those machines you have
there are you able to create AI videos
of Mike
Johnson spitting
up the narrative the racial Narrative of
the left do you have that ability rat
because it feels like the
fies think that you have that ability
here's what I mean by that if we go back
to this tweet uh from from Matt
Walsh I want to show you this thread and
this is important we're going to show
you the video here H but Matt Walsh um
clearly knocking on the new speaker of
the house but let's listen to this video
from Patriot takes here and you can
determine if if you think that this this
guy is you know using the race card or
not I think he is but let's listen and
I've thought often through all these
ordal over the last couple of weeks
about the difference in the experiences
between my two 14-year-old Sons Michael
being a black American and Jack being
white Caucasian they have different uh
challenges uh my son jack has an easier
path he just does there the interesting
thing about both of these kids Michael
and Jack is they're both handsome
articulate really talented kids gifted
by God to do lots of things but the
reality is and no one can tell me
otherwise my son Michael had a harder
time than my son jack is going to have
simply because of the color of his skin
and that's a reality it's an
uncomfortable painful one to acknowledge
uh oh yeah it is uncomfortable and
painful for Mike Johnson I'm sure to
acknowledge I'm sure it is right now
again uh the the facts remain um exactly
clear to me but apparently he adopted
Michael the black 14 when he was
14 and apparently the the kid is an
adult now this was years ago when Mike
Johnson adopted this 14y old boy I know
that that when I say that out
loud it kind of that Mike Johnson
adopted a 14-year-old boy you know what
I mean I mean when they're Republic what
am I supposed to do when you're
religious Republican these days what the
[__] are you supposed to think I mean
Jesus Christ um but let's let's finish
what he says here now what he's saying
is true it's it's
true it's true there is White Privilege
folks there is White Privilege trust
me's eyes knows look at me I know
there's white
privilege I know
it I I I get the benefits of it every
day at one point in my life I didn't
realize that I was receiving benefits
from it no clue I no [__] clue I had
no clue I just thought that's just the
way it
was until I listened I used my ears
right in my
brain to hear other people's experience
and realize that the reality that I was
living
in wasn't exactly the reality that
everyone else was
experiencing based on the color of their
skin okay and that's when I was like oh
okay well you know what I should do I
should use my my empathy
maybe I should do that I should use my
empathy and my rational thinking and
logic to really put together a
worldview that represents my beliefs
around that idea huh ain't that
something I believe in Liberty and
everyone should have rights and freedoms
so I had to come to the conclusion that
you know what it probably isn't a good
thing that we have certain groups of
people have certain privileges that
other people don't and apparent
that's woke as [__] oh that's [__]
woke can you imagine like if there was
even a book out there that kind of
described this you know what I mean like
if there was like some sort of Godly
like figure that was born to a virgin
mother or something I don't know I'm
just kind of making this stuff up as we
go along you know what I mean I don't
know he he became kind of like a messiah
like he would heal people and [__] and
then people were really scared of him
because he was all woke you know had all
these woke ideas and then they what they
did instead of just getting rid of him
they made an example out of him [__]
crucified him you know what I mean I
don't know I'm just making this stuff up
maybe there's a story out there that
Mike could could tell about this but
let's see what he says about pulling the
race guard here that he's trying to pull
because that's what I actually think
Mike Johnson's doing in this interview
he never knew he was GNA be the speaker
of the house and he was trying to
appeal this is like the whole I got a
black friend thing you know what I mean
you ever you ever seen some [__]
do that well I'm not racist I got a
black friend like Trump said there's my
African-American over there look at him
that's my African you remember that clip
that's my African-American over there
when Trump did that same
[__] same [__] in this
clip he's going well I'm not racist
because I doed a black boy it's what
Mike Johnson's doing but the problem is
is doing it he's running smack dab into
the truth right smack dab into the
truth by playing his little I've got a
black friend card here I mean he's
playing it as I adopted a black boy
which again when I say Mike Johnson the
news the new wiener of the house micro
Johnson adopted a 14-year-old boy I know
it it's you start to be like whoa [__]
but let's listen
but people have to recognize that's a
fact what should we do about that here
we go I think that we need uh we really
do need systematic change I think we
need transformative Solutions I think we
we're at a moment where we can begin to
do more to form that more perfect union
as it says in the first so when when a
guy like when a fascist like Mike
Johnson says systematic change and
transformative Solutions I don't like
that when a fascist like this starts
talking like that but you got to
remember how the rights hearing this
okay you got to get in their mindset to
really [__] figure out what the hell
they're so pissed off about this clip
because they're [__] pissed they are
mad as hell about this clip because he's
[__] woke and they don't like it and
the words that they don't like in this
okay is systematic change because the
left narrative is because it's true
there is systematic racism it's
institutional racism it's built in
that's the whole idea of studying
critical race theory in in universities
not in elementary
schools that's the study that's the
actual study of that I don't know if you
know that they don't CRT is actually the
study of the the systematic
institutional
systems that cause racism directly or
indirectly or in intentionally or
unintentionally right that's the study
of that like you're just studying that
thing to see if that's the thing it's
the
theory words you know the right has
trouble but this is um first line of the
Constitution this is the um this is the
problem that the right has with this
with this clip now I want to um go
to let's see it is uh no it's not that
one I gotta get back to it's this one
here no where is that where is that
where is that there is a there was a
comment on this and I wanted to bring it
up and the reason why is because it's it
makes such a good
point um when what the rightwing is
going to do and how it's going to break
them up and how we can draw wedges down
in between using AI because if I can
pull this clip up I may have to uh just
give you the screenshot of it then
you're not going to believe me uh how
did I lose
that um so someone underneath the thread
question rather this was AI like
immediately that was their go-to is nope
this is not Mike Johnson this is not
Mike Johnson this is AI this is a doctor
clip to get us to fight each other you
see that
let me see if I can find that um God
damn it I thought I was gonna have that
oh here it is okay here it
is yep oh boy and they're they're doing
it in Mass they got the Bots doing it
watch this okay here's why AI is so
important so this is Patriot takes tweet
here right let me show you how
narratives are formed with AI right why
this AI so important that we understand
it it says here's the Tweet talking
about it here's the clip right and we go
down in the thread here and the first
post is from sweet P
Jeepers now let's read her
profile let's see if we can hover over
it and it'll pop up well we'll just read
the profile here you go here's this
account look how many she's following
4,900 following and she's got 3900
followers right kind of suspicious on
YouTube because she's a blue check but
look at look at the description here
hash # God hamily # country #e the
people # Patriot here we go it's getting
real hash Trump one magaga
asusa Amer first American flag now I
don't know if you know this but this
this seems like it could be AI right am
I not am I am I off my rocker here this
seems like it could AI is
[Music]
it
a yeah is it real or is it AI it feels
like AI to me does it feel like AI to
you right okay now watch this I know
there's a long way around this but here
is the here's the Tweet right I just
want to prove it um because I could you
know dress this up and make this look
like this but this is on Twitter here is
her her here's her post it says fake
video you see this fake video AI
generated so here is a picture right of
Mike Johnson and his family now what
they're alluding to here is that Mike
Johnson and his wife are white okay
they're white and they have a white
family so how in the world could Mike
Johnson have a black son
well this [__] doesn't understand I
mean I'm sure this [__] understands the
word adoption because I'm sure she if
she is real which she's probably not but
you know who knows if it's real or if
it's
AI or is
it I don't know if it's real or AI but
if she is real if she is real if sweet
pee here is real she probably stands in
front of abortion clinics asking people
to adopt and here she's claiming that
Mike Johnson did not adopt a 14-year-old
boy because I mean
obviously look look there's no there's
no black boy in this
picture that's the evidence literally
that the AI account is claiming that
this video in this thread is
[Music]
AI now again the rightwing Matt Walsh I
want to show it to you again is
attacking full fullon
attacking um Mike Johnson for having
adopted a 14-year-old black son and
understanding institutional racism
because that's T that's really what
happened Mike Johnson adopted a
14-year-old black son he compared it to
his
biological white sun their
experience and now he understands
now he understands that there's
systematic racism right and the right's
pissed off about it that not only does
he understand that truth he he he he
says it out loud now don't get it
twisted because a lot of people are
saying that Mike Johnson is a racist I
absolutely believe
that the way that he brings this
up is is the the way that he brings this
up
and that I've got a black son that's
really weird it almost feels like he
adopted a black son just so he could
have that little shtick but again and
it's all over these these threads right
if you go in these threads and you
scroll down the the right is broken
apart either Mike Johnson is too
woke or this is fake this is AI right
that's that is the [__] thing we need
okay this is how we use this all right
and again I go back to the AI thing we
goof them with AI so now they believe
that Patriot takes here is goofing on
them some of these some of these people
at least that's the narrative that they
want to spend is that Nate Patriot takes
is now using AI to goof on them even
though this isn't AI this is real this
is a real clip
that's the point that's the point of AI
That's How We mock them that's how we
use AI to mock them and we use it to
drive wedges down in between their
narrative because Mike Johnson in this
clip even though he does it in a
disgusting manner he is describing a
real thing which is White Privilege he
is describing white privilege and he's
describing systematic racism and he's
also being very loose about the terms
but he's also describing what you have
to do is institutionally and
systematically you have to make
transform transformational changes to do
that you have to think way outside the
[__] box to make those
transformational changes to to get rid
of institutional racism and it might
even just be you get some white guy with
a beard who's got a ton of white
privilege going on a microphone every
single day the wrestling ball the left
and getting in the brains of these
boneheads and smashing up white
privilege with his white privilege you
got to think way outside the box
sometimes so thanks Mike I appreciate
that but the problem is is that the
right doesn't believe it because this
guy's got to be a racist or this guy's a
woker so let's use it let's use it like
if you see them in the comments and
they're cheering and ay is cheering in
your comments yeah woohoo we love Mike
Johnson he's a fascist he's a Nazi and
we love our Nazi spe speaker give him
this clip give him this clip say well
what about his views on BLM and say it
viscerally well Mike Johnson supports
BLM and antifa really [__] get in
there and dig in on them
right that's what you should do you
should dig at them let them be pissed
show them that they should be pissed
that this guy's not as racist as he
should be because they will be oh he's
not he's not racist enough he's too
woke use that now if you got someone in
your comments that's saying [__] like
well he's not racist
enough you use this same clip in the
opposite
direction I'm telling you it will work
it's a great wedge and I am happy I am
excited that Mike Johnson is now the
wiener of the house the micro Johnson is
the wiener of the house house and I know
a lot of people out there are really um
you know they're really scared that this
election denier is the speaker of the
house and all this kind of stuff but
really um frankly um there's not much
they can do and I know that a lot of
people are scared about you know
certifying the election and that sort of
thing and can they stop it there's
certain rules there's laws there's a
rule of law and also the vice president
of the United States is the one who
holds the Gabel in a joint
session the vice president is KLA Harris
not Mike
Johnson because KLA Harris not only is
the vice president she's second in line
to the presidency but she's also the
president of the Senate which gives her
the gavel in a joint session
so it's it's okay to to understand two
truths at once one truth is that Mike
Johnson is a piece of [__] racist
bigoted
white Christian nationalist Nazi
trash but it's also true that we can use
him as a tool to divide the right that's
the most important part about this
narrative is that we can use him as a
wedge to drive down in between them to
enrage the manga Civil War even more
because the more broken they are the
more divided they are the easier it will
be for democ y to win I'm going to go to
a quick break when we come back bonehead
of the week when we come back on the
Tony Michaels podcast right after this
don't go
anywhere what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
best
sh we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy de's Tam
by the time we reached DC we was 50
strong in number some patriots ran out
of gas along the way we got plenty of
slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast
welcome back to the
[Applause]
show we got someone joining us here
about time get here I I heard you were
over I heard you were cheating on me
that's what the is that is that true uh
it's true I was I was over I was over on
H show the chat was a little upset you
were there you like what happened was
uhuh oh no we want the truth in the full
the Chad wants the [__] truth here
matters here uh no there was this we
were supposed to do it early in the week
and then scheduling and then yeah you
got a checking in a savings account and
Bob goar Bob
hads the to
the yeah so I we finally did it and I
was like all right well like if we're
going to do it Friday I can do it at 9:
to 10 and then I got to go over and do
my show okay yeah yeah all right I mean
that's what happened man that's true
well it was fun I had never done Hal
show before I I haven't been Hal's been
on our show but I've never been over on
he was on the show what but I was gone
oh really oh so I see how it is I see
how it
is but we now we now have seen Gabe
Sanchez and Hal Sparks in the same spot
or was it AI I don't know we can't we
can't tell anymore we can't tell anymore
uh if it's real or if it's AI
yeah is
real or is it
a did you see that the wri is freaking
out over this uh Mike Johnson and
they're like no it's AI he doesn't have
a that the video of him video of him
talking how he's got a black son he was
like oh we adopted him just like The
Blind Side
well he said that he said that out loud
yeah he said like The Blind Side yeah no
no no no he said that yes what so this
totally is I got a I'm not racist I got
a black friend like I'm not racist
we when I started to say it out loud for
the audience earlier um I
said I you changed the DM and the alpha
cook on me I did because we totally
forgot about one of them okay well
that's fine we can go there we can do
all this no but I thought the alpha the
alpha cug is what we said oh yes yes
that's right that's right but it's the
DM that I switched because I was like oh
my God we totally forgot that the story
dropped yesterday cuz again the news is
[__] nuts where's the video where's
the video the video's not it's in the
it's in the video now load load it when
when we go to when we Here's the the
video when we
load when we when we go when we go in to
the studio then you can load it in oh oh
I see there's still time on it that's
why oh it's it's still it's still
working it was still loading I thought
it was done oh oh well see that well you
know you know if you weren if you
weren't cheating on the show here and
I'm bone dude I got all the other I got
those I got the I got the images done I
was like I gotta finish it before I go
on the show because I was like I don't
know what we're gonna talk about so then
I was like I we are gonna talk about
here we never know oh oh well who gives
a [__] and you talk about politics come
on yeah it was just it was just like
talking abouts stuff well I I actually I
think the U Farm Fresh fash let me show
you um so we've got a farm fresh fash
yeah we've got a new uh new thing we're
going with here it's called The Farm the
farm fresh fash but it's your farm to
table fascism Well it Well Facebook to
table um so it's the farm fresh fash
Facebook Uncle Fred you know
thanksgiving's coming up so your Uncle
Fred might um you know here's Uncle Fred
Canon green beans on Facebook is small
rat making all these AI images no the
the the the brain is but I mean you know
he's making them in the laboratory in
the lab he's concocting them as the the
mad scientist right right exactly well
let's let's check in on rat in the uh in
the laboratory here let's see if we can
uh find him in the laboratory this
laboratory keeps getting bigger and
bigger as it goes it is growing I feel
like every day look at look how big it's
getting r r here look at sh that's crazy
that is insane so um this laboratory
that we're building for AI is getting
bigger and bigger we got a lot of cool
things coming and we're trying to um get
the audience um really in the mode of is
it real is it real or is it
AI is it real or is
it I don't know and and and that might
be AI it's a banger dude it's a banger
yeah I know I know that sh slaps I'm
telling you when rat's in the laboratory
rat's making and rat's banging out Beats
these beats hit I'm just telling you
he's these beats be banging bro oh these
beats be be totally bang beats be
banging totally banging I mean here uh
let me give you let me give you some um
since we're going to talk about U Mike
Johnson here let me let me play you this
one this one say Mike Johnson micro
Johnson the wiener of oh micro the
wiener of the house mro micro Johnson
and so here's here's a good one here's
his intro
music it's
the of the
house you know that's pretty good one
here's another one for for the wiener of
the
house
[Music]
Johnson these are all original hits that
rat is making in the laboratory here man
you we say it the chat types it in and
we bang out a Beat Just like that boom
just like that it's the new world that
we live in now the new world order
that's right and we're going to be in
charge of it I don't know if that's a
good thing or not but you know that's
how it goes that's I don't know that's
TBD okay so let's do this let's do bone
end of the week we're not gonna have a
lot of these assets when we go to Bone
end of the week because we don't have we
literally have no I'm talking about the
good music that we have and all that
kind of
stuff I don't know I don't know if it's
G to be in there or not but we're just
going to do a hard cut bone head of the
week here we are in bone end of the week
oh look at that
yeah there it goes wow you just switch
it over you just switch it over yeah see
Swit see the sounds the sounds aren't in
there um that's just how it goes
sometimes that's unfortunate that you
you can't get it over like you have to
copy over the theme and then you'd have
to go through and then you have to match
stuff well see the challenge is is that
in our virtual Studio here that the
people get to see you know on the screen
I have to I I have it to where I switch
Studios but you know thinking about it I
could probably just you know kind of
yeah but that means that every time you
update the main one you have to but I
guess it wouldn't be too bad because
then you're just adding well but I could
add the bone end of the week Assets in
the main one so they're there but the
list gets really long you know what I
mean yeah yeah yeah it gets really long
just shuffle through that'll happen
that'll happen what being long or being
micro no long okay all right Democrats
are you know they got that Big D right
big big D oh I think this is got D
energy that big Democratic energy yeah
so so I've got I've got the uh the video
loaded in now so we're ready to go with
bone end of the week but let's show
let's show the audience our contestants
here we've got representative Anthony
devolder ah excuse me George Santos yes
guar R yeah otherwise known as guitar
rage uh Jenna I get farted on by Rudy
and get coid uh
Ellis and then the micro Johnson the
the the election denying Speaker of the
House the wiener of the
house you know I I will say all three of
them are very similar but also
specifically Jen Ellis and Mike Johnson
they both
believe that Hugo Chavez was involved in
the Dominion [__] voting machines
that's a little well I mean um I mean
but I mean are we surprised by a man who
I'm going to assume believes the the
Earth is flat he does believe that the
Earth was created 6,000 years ago is
that specific 6,000 years ago you're
gonna have to give me send me these
clips because I need to know he said
it's on as Wikipedia man it say serious
this dude he believe yeah dinosaurs went
on the on to Noah's Arc the guy is crazy
it's his Wikipedia yeah dude he's on his
Wikipedia I will say this a lot of
people are like oh my God this guy is
scary scary and yes he is scary he's a
fascistic zealot he's you know nobody
and that was by Design but I also don't
think he's going to be as successful as
Republicans wanted to be well I actually
believe that's that's also the design
here is for him not to be as successful
as Republicans want him to be um and
what I mean what I mean by that is that
that that's the indication because
apparently he's doing he uh they're
really working on a stop Gap measure
they're not working on a CR
now what a stop Gap essentially is is a
punting of the CR so they're punting it
until they need to get another deal to
get a continuing resolution because what
A continuing resolution is is to
continue the appropriating of funds that
you currently have right and a stop Gap
just gives you the ability to keep the
government open until you come to a deal
with a new continuing resolution and how
you're going to fund the government um
so it's clear that Mike Johnson knows
that he has to have Democrats by doing a
stop Gap and what I mean by that I mean
that's that's going to be the biggest
test
that we see is as much as Republicans
want him to be the Maga you know king or
Maga Jesus or whatever label or giving
that guy but uh when it when push comes
to shove on this he's gonna have to work
with Democrats and if he doesn't then I
mean the shit's gonna he's going to be
holding the bag of [__] it's not gonna
be the Democrats rats Will Stand United
212 voting for whatever measure that
helps helps Americans Republicans will
be caught fighting each other oh my God
here's the stop Gap um that that he's
trying to work on here that micro John
is it
moving you moving it I might be moving
it I might oh it oh that's what it was
it felt like there was an earthquake and
I was like oh that's a cool effect yeah
well I mean you know we can do effects
here sort of it was more of just a shake
it was like oh it's all crumbling below
us right right but I mean that's
essentially what he's going to try to do
is put a Band-Aid um and so it doesn't
crumble all below us and and again I was
telling the audience before that they're
doing this to get through the holidays
because that's where the farm fresh fash
Uncle Fred came in because yeah the farm
frash uh Facebook Uncle Fred yeah I know
it's a long way around doesn't want they
don't want him to be talking to you know
his libtard nephews and his libtard
nieces trying to tell why it's
Republicans fault that he's pissed off
right they don't want that and the
government shutdown will really cause
that conversation whereas if they keep
the government open there's not having
that he's gonna be like Joe Biden wrote
a check or or or James Biden wrote a
check for $200,000 to do a loan
repayment to Joe Biden like that'll be
the that'll be the thing that they're
talking about right um instead of the
government shutdown so Republicans got
to kick this can into next year H and
Mike Johnson's got to do that now that's
the reason why he's on here but I gotta
go I want to go first uh should we do
Jenna Ellis or your buddy George George
let's go to let's go to George because
there was actually a recent development
this morning really really okay yeah
well he pleaded well okay we'll talk
about okay first off here's a here's the
video of his own Republican colleagues
from the state of New
York okay yesterday and of course this
happens after they got what they wanted
they got this new speaker in 220 voted
for him woohoo or whatever it was
um now that they got their speaker and
they're like okay all the drama is over
let's kick out this guy that being
George Santos these are the people that
are from New York Representatives who
also or who feel like they should remove
George Santos because he has a stain and
an embarrassment on Democracy which I do
not disagree
with uh now these are these are what you
call Republicans though right these are
Republicans that are doing this these
are Republicans yes I mean I don't know
if I would give them the name of like oh
they're a republican but they're you
know they're Maga they're whatever
Republicans well let's let's see what
they say about uh Anthony devolder
George Santos maybe a congress person
maybe not Mr Speaker pursuant to Clause
2a1 of Rule n i rise to give notice of
my intent to raise a question of the
Privileges of the house the form of the
resolution is as follows house
resolution
773 providing for the expulsion of
Representative George Santos from the
House of Representatives whereas George
Anthony dealer Santos known as George
Santos was elected to represent New
York's thirdd congressional district in
the House of Representatives on November
8th 2022 whereas after election day it
was revealed George Santos lied about a
significant portion of his background
including his education and previous
employment whereas George Santos has a
long history of misrepresenting his and
his family's connections okay I gotta
stop there I gotta point something out
okay now now they they give [__] to John
fedman for wearing a hoodie instead of
wearing a suit is this guy wearing a
[__] fleece Hood he's wearing the
same thing what the [__] is he's wearing
the same thing that George S here let me
hold on hold on hold on what the [__] is
that why is this guy wearing I mean
they're giving a lot of [__] to Federman
for wearing a hoodie but at least
they're not wearing he's not wearing a
hoodie underneath his suit wait wait
hold on hold on let me show you let me
show you because this look is this a new
style no no no no no it's not a new
style because if we see here let me give
you this send this over here this is the
exact same
style that link let me let me see just
so people go back go back to it really
quick uhuh
oh wait wait wait yeah go back to the
right so we got Blazer we got pin we got
sweater zip up up just just just a
little Ace like a fle a p fleece then we
then we got a tie and we got a a a
collared shirt okay right now go to
George Santos okay is it the first one
there or the second one and that one's
not working there's something uh there's
something crazy about these oh here we
go okay all right so this is this is the
uh this is George Santos here let's
let's uh open this up here sorry it
takes a second Boop you know you can
open it up and you can say just share
this tab yeah what if there's a way to
do that then we need to you open up new
tabs and at the top it says share this
tab instead does it really where does it
say that no it doesn't it does not say
that God I don't know you're working on
an old machine Boomer all right
so all right so if we go back
right we got Blazer we got pin it does
it says it wait it says it oh my God
wait wait wait wait I'm I'm look at that
see there we go holy [__] this is the
noob is teaching you something I guess
so all right all right well teach me
teach me about this fashion thing tell
me why this is fashionable all right so
here we have we have Blazer [__] is this
we have zipper down pullover sweater we
have tie and we have collared shirt
go back to the other
one use the little tab yeah there we go
look at that [__] Blazer pin pullover
zip up sweater tie collared
shirt I'm saying as much as he hates
George Santos they sure dress alike what
is is this a thing now is this what
people are doing is where they where it
like this I don't know I mean here
here's what a lot of people said they're
like for someone who claims to be gay
they certainly don't have a lot of
fashion sense that was what was said by
other people early on when George Santos
joined because he was wearing these
sweaters and a t-shir and a and a collar
shirt and a tie and a blazer everyone's
like why are you bundling up why do you
need layers it's not that cold this
seems like a this seems like a fancy
Steve Bannon look like they're going for
the this is like the fancy this like the
fan B yeah it's like the the seven layer
dip you know when you're at a Super Bowl
party this is the you know the seven
layer the seven layer dip [__] yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah seven layer [__] all
right let's go back to the the video
here of this of this turd speaking of
[__] to major events including the
Holocaust September 11th terrorist
attacks and the Pulse Nightclub
shooting whereas on May 9th 2023 George
Santos was indicted on 13 counts of wire
fraud moneya laundering stealing public
funds and lying on federal financial
disclosure forms to the House of
Representatives you know what you know
what's funny about this clip yeah it's
Republicans telling the truth oh man
that's something else well they they
only they only like to tell the truth
when it benefits them I guess so a't
that funny though like they're telling
the truth like yeah okay that's the
truth like keep going with the truth you
guys should say it more of say the truth
more often whereas a Federal grand jury
indicted an aid to George Santos's
campaign on charges of wire fraud and
identity theft for defrauding potential
donors by impersonating speaker Kevin
McCarthy's former Chief of Staff I'm not
going to lie here I'm I'm GNA point this
out George Santos definitely is doing
this look better now that I'm looking at
this you know I'm listening to him tell
the truth which is fascinating uh at but
the other fascinating thing here is that
George Santos actually does this look
better this guy this guy not only does
it look like this suit is not tailored
right but it looks like his sweater
doesn't fit as well underneath the coat
I'm just I'm just giving my two cents
there um you know about the Fashions
thing let's let's keep going whereas on
October 5th 2023 George Santos's former
campaign Treasurer pled guilty to
falsifying campaign Finance records
including lying about a $500,000 loan
that George Santos claimed to have
donated to the campaign himself whereas
on October 10th 2023 George Santos was
federally charged with an additional 10
criminal counts whereas the additional
charges were serious in nature including
conspiracy to commit offenses against
the United States of America wire fraud
aggravated identity theft access device
fraud false statements to the Federal
Election Commission and falsifying
records to obstruct the commission
whereas the indictment outlined a vast
amount of evidence against sanos
including conversations he all right all
right we get it he's a criminal yeah we
know he's one of you he's a republican
what else I mean just say that just say
he's a republican he's one of us and we
want to expel him because he's one of us
now you sent me a video here and the
video is um of George Santos here and he
is he is
leaving the um the courthouse because he
pled guilty not guilty excuse me he pled
not guilty yeah please if he played
guilty he played not guilty today to the
additional
listen ho
ho
[Music]
you K
my God damn put that liar I haven't
watched this video so I did not expect
that one to
[Music]
happen
my
God fire put that liar in the you're not
a well
Congressman oh my God uh so proper
mockery there and yelling and screaming
at the mhm at the weirdo George Santos
as he exits the courthouse this
afternoon after um pleading not guilty
to the superseding indictment um where
he was charged with not only identity
theft um but credit card fraud am I
right on that it it was aggravated
identity theft credit card fraud and
then
uh it was also cons I forget what the
other charges but basically conspiring
yeah conspiring with Nancy marks to
mislead not only the public uh but the
Republican
National uh party around his financial
situation well there you go there's
where George Santos is on this week's
bonehead of the week now let's move on
to I got farted on by Rudy Giuliani and
got Co from his fart in Michigan while
we were at hearing Jenna Ellis well what
could possibly Jenna Ellis be on the
moon end of the week for gab Sanchez
it's weird it's almost like Jenna Ellis
was on there because she admitted that
she was [__]
wrong oh oh oh oh that must hurt the did
she did she she pleaded she pleaded
guilty guil uh guilty I know for a
person who said that they were innocent
and that they had nothing to be ashamed
of and that they had everything that
they knew was to be true oh is this
George Santos I I think this is also an
image of George Santos getting out of
the vehicle at 3 left the Gord house
with the what looks to be credit look at
him walking the plank yeah look at this
byee I like see do you what I do you see
what I mean about the uh the see he even
got the fashion style here if you want
to take a look at it look at that he's
much better than the other guy with the
death pin you see that that's pretty
good yeah that's pretty good I'm not
going to lie that's pretty goddamn Clos
to George Santos is it oh my God this AI
is getting crazy it's getting crazy so
do you have the clip of um uh her crry
yeah that's the one I want I definitely
want the one of her crry let's do that
give me one second let me one second
let's let's let's do the one of her um
pouting and boohoo because that's the
important one if we wanna if we want to
show the audience exactly how this went
down now if you're not aware Jenna Ellis
is a is an ambulance Chaser from
Colorado somehow she became the attorney
to the Trump campaign um we've showed
clips of the press conference before
where Rudy Giuliani came out announced
that this is the legal team and cydney
pal and Jenna Ellis he even said their
names as they were members of the legal
team for the Trump campaign that's the
most important part they called
themselves and I don't know the exact
and someone in the chat can can let me
know but there was a certain Elite
Strike Force I think is what she said
she said something along the lines of
like let me see hold on Elite Strike
Force Jenna Lis that's that's like the
code name that they used yes I take
responsibility as a lawyer very
seriously Trump Elite Strike Force
attorney Jenna
Ellis changes tune and plead guilty well
that's the other when she gave her spe
she was like we're an elite St I don't
know I'm doing Trump uh she was like
we're an elite strike for we're we're
we're in Elite Strike Force the best
some some people say we're better than
SEAL Team Six we're pretty good well
let's see let's see exactly how good she
is here uh in this clip where she
is gonna try to gain our sympathy
because G Sanchez it really feels like
in this clip she's not gonna be sad
because she did something wrong she's
sad because she got caught but let's
take a listen that's how it
goes to address the court
as an attorney who is also a Christian I
take my responsibilities as a lawyer
very seriously and I Endeavor to be a
person of sound moral and ethical
character in all of my dealings in the
wake of is she telling jokes is she
telling [__] jokes as a lawyer of
sound moral and ethical character please
get off the [__] stage okay you're
not going to win the award this year oh
my God
this is so pathetic but just keep going
we like we like to mock you for being
pathetic 2020 presidential election
loser I believed that challenging the
results on behalf of President Trump
should be pursued in a just and legal
way I endeavored to represent my client
to the best of my ability I relied on
others including lawyers with many more
years of experience than I to provide me
with true and reliable information
especially since my role involved
speaking to the media and to legislator
just because okay I love that I she's
like I listened to lawyers who had many
more years of experience okay
look uh just because someone has been
something for a period of time doesn't
mean that the experience is good okay
the idea that she's like uh I respected
these lawyers they had all these years
of experience your
example that you're giving here is Rudy
Giuliani and Sydney Powell one of which
has already flipped and giving up dirt
for a [__] plea deal I actually think
Rudy Giuliani tried to flip and they
were like no they might be like no no no
no no no you see you don't you no you're
gonna go broke you're gonna die in jail
and we're all gonna laugh at you but I
just love that you like years of
experience it's like again doesn't mean
that they're good right shitty
experience you have years of shitty
experience you you can have years of
experience and you can be God awful you
can be like oh man I've got years of
experience playing Bas and some like so
what's your like batting average like
zero I got your I still really suck I
still because it sucks to suck I suck at
micro Johnson well apparently she sucks
at apparently she sucks at acting too
because Trina 6 here on Twitch says
she's this is horrible acting and it is
it's really horrible she's probably a
better actor than a lawyer though even
it's horrible what I did not do but
should have done your honor was to make
sure that the facts the other lawyers
alleged to be true were in fact true in
the frenetic pace of attempting to raise
challenges to the election in several
States including Georgia I failed to do
my due diligence I believe in and I
value election Integrity if I knew then
what I know now I would have declined to
represent Donald Trump in these
post-election challenges I look back on
this whole experience with deep remorse
for those failures of M your honor I
have taken responsibility already before
the Colorado bar who censured me and I
now take responsibility before this
court and apologize to the people of
thank uh she did not take responsibility
in Colorado because what she did is she
signed an agreement with the judge and
then she goes into public saying no I
didn't do that she like I didn't admit I
didn't admit to lying I never I never I
never said I no no no no no no no no you
don't no no no you didn't listen so yeah
Jenna Ellis went from Elite she went
from elite team elite elite Elite Strike
Force
to Elite cry Force we'll say right here
here She is in the cry Force here she is
this is her official Elite cry
Force maybe maybe someone in the lab can
work on a song that's Elite cry Force I
don't know rant can we get a uh can we
get a uh maybe an elite an elite cry for
force the way that I I have the the
audio or like the sound in my head it's
like the trans like 1980s or early 90s
cartoon where it's like guitar riff you
know it's
like Elite craft force or it's kind of
like Team America you know let's check
in on rant see if if he's he's still
working in the
lamp he's just working away pounding
away at those Tunes so we'll see if we
can get uh may maybe we can get maybe we
can get elite elite Strike Force all
right let's go to our next bonee head U
the dishonorable mention tell me why you
pulled an audible here because we were
going to have
Margery Taylor Yeti Petty
green we were gonna have that we're
gonna have that and then I was like H
who better than clearence Thomas yeah
the man who the man who got a
20 what was it 267 278 I'm trying to
remember the exact number let me
see
um
$267,000 loan for a luxury
RV what I thought you were gonna say he
got fined for his crimes is what I
thought you were gonna
say no no no no no no they won't they
won't do that not unless they not unless
they put in some [__] guard rails uh
in the future but I don't know if that's
going to happen anytime soon Clarence
Thomas failed to fully repay a
$267,000 loan that he was given for a
luxury RV back in
200 uh what was it you know what's funny
about that it was 1999 and it was
forgiven in 2008 you know what's funny
about that is the these him and his his
Q andon wife oh man they take all kinds
of pictures our VN apparently a't that
funny that the thing that they act like
is like all middle class and wholesome
and [__] they they got it paid for by oh
everything who who who gave him this
loan do we know who gave him this loan
he goes by the name of uh Anthony
welters Anthony welters no no no not not
not the Hitler man not which by the way
uh side note yeah I was reading this
article today about Kanye West I just
want to give a side note because we
haven't you know we Haven mentioned
Kanye in a minute I feel like this is
going in a Hitler Direction here oh my
God it is four strikes to a swastika
um oh [__] okay so this is just an
excerpt from this Kanye
West showed a troubling fixation on Jews
and Hitler yeah we remember that and
this is this is the um this article is
about Adidas and Kanye West and how for
some time they knew that he was
problematic but they didn't do anything
about it until he went on to things like
Alex Jones and professed his love for
Hitler but literally he said out loud I
love hit like yeah now you ready listen
to this at a 2013 meeting 10 years ago
this has been a while ago 10 years ago
okay at a 2013 meeting with Adidas
designers at the company's headquarters
in
Germany he drew a swastika on one of
their sketches he later f hold on nope
no no no that's not moment here he later
told a Jewish Adidas manager to kiss a
portrait of Hitler every
day and then yet is this just like out
of
nowhere it was a it was a this feels
like Hitler Tourette's you know what I
mean like he's just he's just well he's
like I'm bipolar it's like bipolar
doesn't make you [__]
anti-semitic uh pretty sure that's not
on the list of like symptoms okay so he
later told a Jewish Adidas manager to
kiss a portrait of Hitler every day and
Wes told Adidas call that he admired
Hitler's command of propaganda now this
was from for people who are wondering
this is a Washington Post article that
talks about the the development and work
between Adidas and Kanye West and how
they basically became dependent on Kanye
West because of the Yeezys uh
footline it's crazy crazy anyway side
note just want to talk about Hiller
because I read that this morning and I
literally woke
up talk about Hitler huh yeah I was like
I I woke up and I was like oh
notification from Washington Post like
it's the post with the most is like a
little digest and I it was like Kanye
West I was like oh [__] what do he do
now and then I scrolled and I was like
holy [__] like a lot is there of
different events that have been [__]
timelined and and mapped out anyway so
oh my gosh is
this he
crack yes
nice Elite C
for all right enough of that enough of
that that's the elite cry Force that's
all right look at that the lab [__]
working up Beats the lab rat is dropping
beats in the lab thank you thank you rat
for uh boom getting us the uh amazing
the elite the elite cry Force we're
gonna find out we're gonna be like oh
man who's small rat or like what is
small rat and then we're gonna be like
we don't know man he's just like this
right this source of content you feed it
into the machine and the rat
goes Y and he
[__] [__] he eats the cheese and he
shits out content
he eats the cheese and he shits out
content that rat bastard he okay so
let's go back to the Bone head of the
week got a little distracted there um
let's go to the alpha cuck Donald Trump
got cucked this week are you kidding me
is this is this a week with seven days
of end and why or something he got cut
yeah it's crazy yeah what happened what
happened well Michael Cohen happened
Michael Cohen melen Michael Cohen showed
up do we have a good video because
there's there's several videos back and
forth between Trump and and and C but
you have a specific video that you're
thinking of when Michaels um um because
there was was there much video of him
testifying I don't think there was a lot
of
videoy I haven't seen here's what I will
say I know that it is televis or like it
is got cameras in there yeah yeah yeah
but uh I haven't I haven't actively
looked out for like an in
courtroom Source because the only clips
that I catch on Twitter are the ones
where he's talking before or after he's
in the court or or it's Trump in the
court like yeah yeah I you [__] my
diaper I just [__] my diaper you know
and he wants his but he did run out of
there's a video what I want to bring up
is where he runs out of the court and
he's like you know what while you're
bringing up that clip maybe maybe we can
get rat to get us a picture from inside
the courtroom of the manga uh Clown King
sitting all pissed off while Michael
Cohen is testifying against him in open
court I bet I bet we can get a glimpse
into what that looked like but what's
the clip you're going to play because I
played some back and forth the other day
because I think there was one where
Michael Cohen was walking in and I
believe he said that someone is asking
about the reunion because him and Donald
Trump had not seen each other in the
same room for quite some time and
Michael Cohen said oh it should be a
hell of reunion or something like that a
cozy reunion or something of that nature
um but there was a lot of uh Michael
Cohen went to the microphones which
Donald Trump doesn't really know how to
he stands back from the microphones and
yells really loud his weird marago is
worth the gazillion dollars and like
okay so we should T it tax it for a
zillion no it's not worth a gazillion
dollars it's not worth a gazillion like
which is it don't don't actually okay
well disregard what I said it's not
worth over a billion dollars right uh
never mind that it's actually worth they
said it was worth $ 18 million um yeah
no it's worth like five million right
right it's way it's it's worth nothing
really honestly if you you why do you
guys why do you guys just keep asking
stop asking how much is worth stop
bringing it up and they're like you keep
bringing it up you're the one keep
saying it out loud that it's a gazillion
dollars like and that's you know I'm not
really exaggerating much when I say that
that's how he's saying it is it it's
worth a gazillion dollar like gazillion
dollars that's how much I'm worth and
also
so here here is Grandpa outside the this
this is also
uh this is uh Ben and Michael Cohen this
is Michael Cohen responding to the video
of Donald Trump coming out okay let's
let's
listen this is after he storms out the
the Secret Service is like oh [__] okay
just aded we won
there's Eric
Trump he just admitted that we won the
trial make
it oh we won and he how many times has
he actually said this he said this
several times when he comes out he's
like we won they just proved I'm right
and they're like well if that's the case
wouldn't the [__] thing be over with
like wouldn't they when when they you
don't understand we've got all the
evidence and they're like yeah we have
all the evidence of you committing fraud
no that's not what it was what it was
was me trying to benefit myself
financially and they're like yeah that's
called FR no it's not no it's not n boo
boo what do I put throw on you sticks on
you but not me it's like what it's weird
because they've already figured out that
he committed fraud they've already
decided and the judge and even before
this trial started the judge was like
yeah this is no this is not good man you
committed fraud you you did a bad bad
thing here and he's B this trial is just
to decide like how much he's not going
to be worth right like that's that's
what this is about it's not about rather
you did it or not dummy like we're
trying to figure out how deep it is and
how much money you should owe like
that's the whole point and the judge is
really pissed off here and the reason
why is because Donald Trump and his
attorneys thought that they could bully
the judge by selecting a bench trial and
they could bully him into not letting um
him go broke but it's not working
because the judge is actually already
already charged him $15,000 for breaking
a gag order so like Donald Trump is
already wait they increased I thought it
was 10,000 well no it was five first and
then 10 right oh got it yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay well let's let's see let's see
what the response here
is Eric leading him no this way pops
this way this way I will say I will say
that I mean when was the last time that
you ever saw Trump in front of a
microphone in under five seconds and
listen to the way he's speaking like he
ran out of oxygen in his lungs Jud is
really and and it's really unfair and
also then you got you know you got Eric
sitting there patting him on the back
you know like hey don't worry Dad don't
worry dad you know yeah you better start
worrying because there's gonna be a real
problem
here there's Michael Cohen responding to
the video and I'm not sure what happened
in the courtroom that would make Donald
Trump come out and
say we just won we just won the trial
like what no you didn't
God it's amazing you don't you don't
understand we're innocent they just
proved it they put a guy who's a liar
and as zephie's put in here he [__]
lied for you man he was paid to lie for
you the idea that Donald Trump is like
you don't understand this guy you're
putting up as a boldfaced liar
right yeah he was you paid him to lie
yeah for you like you gave money to
cover up things and then lie about them
and now you're saying no no no that's
not actually what I used him for it's
like oh what did you using for him and
that's why we're here is because you did
those things so Donald Trump gets the
alpha cook of the week which he should
probably we should make a spe special
category where he gets it every single
week around that time here we got to go
to the winner here oh
mikro
Johnson election denying speaker of the
house I told you I would give you the
clip of him talking about uh go to the
the first the first link I sent you the
one from Don Lewis the very okay let's
see if we can get the Don Lewis clip
going I'm fairly certain this is the
clip where he talks about uh basically
pulling a Blindside okay so this is the
the uh oh well we we I I'm not racist
because I adopted a black son is that
the thing that you're talking about that
that sentiment okay here is the one that
getting the one that's getting magot to
turn on them right here we go here's the
clip here on Twitter here we go uh you
live up uh in boa City near Shar port
and you and your wife a long time ago
adopted a 14-year-old African-American
young man and raised him uh as along
with your other children tell me about
how that gave you some perspective on
this yeah sure we we we took Michael in
almost 20 years ago uh he was wait wait
on The Blind Side wasn't isn't the the
yeah okay I'm just making sure that they
were both named
Michael it's a very common name it
really is I I'm just making sure I'm
getting these points correct before I
mock this I mean it's just like Mike
Johnson
is I'm gonna go on a limb here and say
if you were to yell out Mike Johnson in
a busy mall right you would prob 20
people would turn around be like huh
right right okay let's keep going he
adopted Michael all right he was 14 I
often that the easiest way to summarize
your story is I asked friends have you
seen the movie The Blind Side that was
our story except my Michael was not an
NFL prospect a similar story to that
and whoa whoa so he's like whoa
dude oh my God this is so disgusting so
I played the clip earlier where he's
describing that the other one that Matt
Walsh is really pissed off about that
Patriot takes posted now now I want to
say um Gabe I don't know if you know
this but the rightwing is really divided
on this clip and the reason why is
because he's saying the [__] that they
don't want him to say about the
systematic racism and institutional
racism Theory right right and here's the
here's the problem is that they're like
no this is AI and this is what I've been
trying to tell the audience is that like
this AI stuff is going to come into the
conversation whether you like it or not
yeah like and it's gonna be part of this
election whether you like it or not like
we're not gonna get around it it's so
Advanced and it's accelerating so fast
that we're not going to stop it so we
might as well you know use it on our
side The Good the good guys against the
baddies that are trying to use AI
against us and they're weaponizing ai ai
not just in the form of AI but
questioning rather stuff as AI right so
the right's going one side of the right
is pissed off that Mike Johnson uh is
saying yes there's systematic racism and
there's such thing as white privilege
because that's what he says in the clip
right which he's he's correct Mike
Johnson is like a broken clock it's
right twice a day or something you know
not maybe Mike Johnson maybe ain't right
twice a day maybe like twice in his
lifetime that instance he is correct
there is systematic racism it definitely
needs transformation change um to get
rid of that institutional racism which
is the study of critical race Theory you
are correct um but him saying that his
14-year-old son that he adopted which is
really weird to say that Mike Johnson
adopted a 14-year-old boy when you say
that out loud knowing what you know
about Mike Johnson that gets really
weird in and of itself but when he
Compares it to the blind he's like okay
so let me explain why I have a black son
to all my white friends out there okay
look it ain't because I like black
people it's more like The Blindside type
movie do you know what I mean do you
know what mean look look look look I
found this child didn't really have a
mother or a father and his family and
his like life and uh you know at the end
of the day we just felt like as the
white Savior Jesus Christ love him uh
that we were going to come in and we're
going to save Michael because and then
watch the rest of the clip watch what he
says oh my God this is so gross we took
him in as our own and and Michael is now
doing uh great you know this is 20 years
later he's in his mid-30s he lives in
California oh I can see where this is
going I can see white white where this
is going I can see white where this is
going four children of his own he and
Adon have a great family life and he
says to people he shares his testimony
that oh God were it not for our
intervention in his life that he would
certainly have joined a gang gotten on
drugs up in prison on the street
somewhere and that's the har
reality children of our own and my
oldest son jack ironically this year is
14 and I've oh so he's saying let let me
give the audience an idea what he's
saying why I said I know white where
this is going he's saying without my
white
saviors I would be just like all the
other inwords with a hard R that's
exactly what Mike Johnson is saying
there Mike Johnson taking credit
disgusting piece of [__]
man so gross and the other thing too is
like his son went to woke ass lib turd
California oh my God but you look at
this guy and he's like oh yeah if it
wasn't for me he would have been dead on
the street addicted to drugs in prison
or you know whatever and it's like just
because
he's black doesn't mean
druged yeah he's gonna fall into one of
those categories anyone I mean like
obviously in society and he admits it in
the clip where he's like look my white
son doesn't have life as hard as my
black adopted son like that's the harsh
reality is one is better off than the
other which is
insane that he would even admit that but
Mike Johnson plays into the stereotypes
of saying well he's black so he must to
be in up like he would have ended up
getting in trouble now whether whether
his son Michael actually admitted that
or was uh push to believe
that but Mike Mike Johnson right here is
pushing this idea that without him
without his wife and without the grace
and goodness of their lord white
jesus they would have never been able to
save this child oh that white jesus you
know do the white thing Keith Lacy on
YouTube says do do the white thing
that's right do the white thing oh my
God he ran straight into the [__]
truth and then he was like yeah I'm
totally racist I'm totally racist let me
let me tell you let me tell you I'm RAC
I am and and frankly for the right to be
so pissed off about this interview like
they should be excited about this
because not only is he able to embrace
the the the idea of white privilege but
n then he's able to pair it with this
disgusting white savior type narrative
oh my God a it's so [__] gross these
people are [__] disgusting and that's
why I say if the right-wing is pissed
off about this interview about Mike
Johnson telling the truth that there is
White Privilege [__] it use it when
they're in the comments talking about
how great Mike Johnson is just just cut
the clip where Mike Johnson's describing
CRT and just feed it to these [__]
fascist trolls just [__] feed it to
them just give it to them smash him with
that hammer divide up these stupid
bastards and the reason why is because
if we don't we're gonna have more stupid
bastards like this guy right here Mike
Johnson good Lord that's no it's no
wonder you guys chose Mike Johnson this
bonehead of the week thanks wiener of
the house thanks a lot wiener of the
house the election denying
speaker mikro Johnson the election
denying abortion
Banning women hating white savior
complexing woman
hating there's so many
mansplaining right Social Security
Medicare bashing small dick oh it's
total it's total micro Johnson energy
here on bone of the week thanks Mike
micro Johnson for being the bone of the
week let's give him is
[Music]
[Applause]
due
[Music]
oh bone head of the week mikro Johnson
the wiener of the house thanks a lot for
playing everyone stick around right
after the music we'll be right back with
some announcements right after
[Music]
this
Speaker of the House speak of the house
Wier of the house he's the Wier of the
house he's the election what is
it it's the election n Speaker of the
[Music]
House
the election denying speaker of the
house thanks Mike Johnson for playing
bonehead of the week that's the first
time he's ever been on bonehead of the
week because his first time we ever knew
who this scumbag
was I'm sure he will be on it again oh
and again sure he will do more dumb
ridiculous insane bigoted fascist like
things and again and like I said
earlier I understand people's concerns
and how dangerous he can be in terms of
his beliefs and ideologies and how
aggressive he is
but any bills that are passed in the
house are essentially dead of Dead on
Arrival in the
Senate and on top of that Mike
Johnson has to deal with the Democrats
in working with them to actually pass
legislation around the budget so look
what's going to happen here is this guy
is going to be
essentially another cuck because he
can't do he he has to do what Maga and
Matt Gates and them wanted to do or else
bye-bye he gets voted out well you know
I think he cut a deal because they're
talking about that there's conversation
that he's going to uh try to change that
rule oh the motion yeah the motion they
were talking about that with Jim Jordan
which I was like oh this is such like
take your ball and go home type [__]
this is like I got it a certain way and
now I'm going to [__] shut the door
on you guys
well they're all wieners he's just the
wiener of the house
[Music]
nowson the Wier of the house mikro
Johnson thanks for joining us everyone
don't forget Gabe Sanchez does a live
show every single Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday right after this show what was
that live on YouTube and twitch and
don't forget to go check out how he
cheated on us today over at H Sparks oh
my God I didn't cheat I just fit it in
before and I got a little I got like an
appetizer meal check out that re play
you get a chance I like how I like gay
but you know you know how it goes oh no
we're glad you were on H Sparks I'm glad
because we have sparklers here every
single every single day we always got
sparklers here the sparklers are always
welcome we love the sparklers we love
the [__] fam give a shout out to the
mods uh they're doing such a great job
whether it's on Facebook or YouTube or
twitch or Discord don't forget to go
join the Discord we're going to have
some fun this weekend and I know I know
we're going to have fun on patreon I've
got the Sunday rant going on um so don't
forget that let me drop the Discord in
the comments here we're gonna we got a
new arcade over there now that we're
going to be playing games on it's gonna
get wild over on Discord so go join that
go join that and also don't forget to go
to gab's YouTube channel and check out
gab's YouTube channel he's got what was
that not the live one but what was that
releasing all the time every single week
just go to I'll have another one yeah
tell us I I will have another episode of
what was that coming out today or
tomorrow it'll be on the
censure uh that representative balent
did on Margie Taylor green now whether
or not that actually gets passed it
probably will just get tabled but she
came out with a list of over
40 incendi like incendiary comments vile
comments over the last like five to six
years and she was like on this day she
said this on this day she said that like
for 10 to 11 minutes I won't make people
stay through the whole thing in terms of
watching that footage but I also go
through and I'm like here are the
receipts of the leral horse's
mouth giving it out uh so expect an
episode there I will probably end up
doing one on Mike Johnson uh and and
just giving people a background of who
this fascist is well that's good go and
we want to thank small rat for all the
uh all the
laboratory casting
spells uh AI that we had today thanks
for uh submitting those today uh small
rat as we go and I'm sorry for the
technical difficulties at the beginning
of the show but that's how it works it's
live do it live as it says on gab
Sanchez's inro what was that live and
don't forget to go to IM gab sanchez.
comom follow him there we'll see you
this weekend on patreon on Sunday same
time same place on Monday right here
YouTube Facebook and twitch surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
in political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow
toning on social media @ the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
you came from you [__] [__] hey
drag Li you want me to scream like an
elder hor I'll give you a [__] show
that will make HP Lovecraft look like Dr
Seuss's on acid as for the rest of your
losers in chat forget about sleepy Joe
and copia athine and get ready for dark
Brandon time I'm going to tear this [__]
up like a porn star at a swingers party
and just remember when it comes to E4
plans we're going to build back better
than ever before with or without your
sorry
asses listen up you weaklings Biden
thinks he's owning me big joke I've been
owning clowns like him since the day I
popped out on my mama's tremendous
uterus and let me tell you sleepy Joe
ain't got [__] on me that guy couldn't
negotiate a deal to save his life and as
for his ice cream addiction it's like
watching a goddamn child with a sugar
high well soft world I don't know what's
on sleep sleepy Joe's son's laptop and
frankly I don't give a flying [__] but
based on how [__] scile he is
probably some pictures of him playing
with his balls or some [__] like that
believe me nothing good could be on
there listen here Jack I don't give a
flying [__] about Hunter Biden's laptop
nor do I care about your sorry ass
opinion unlike you I don't get off the
plane with my balls all day I'm too busy
being the goddamn president and on that
note why don't you stick your head up
your own ass and see if you can find
your missing brain